the sanctions on the Nordstrom to
project are included in a wide-ranging
US defense spending bill President Trump
signed that legislation into law at a
ceremony held at Andrews Air Force Base
just outside Washington so it's now my
honor to sign the 2020 National Defense
Authorization Act into law the sanctions
target companies involved in the almost
10 billion euro project to double the
pipeline capacity carrying Russian
natural gas to Europe's leading economy
Germany most of that pipeline has been
completed all seized the company
building the unfinished section through
Danish territorial waters announced it
was halting its work in anticipation of
the new law Washington had made it clear
in advance that non-compliance would
have consequences you know senator Cruz
who's the sponsor of the bill wrote a
letter to the CEO of all seas today
basically saying as soon as this bill is
signed into law you're out of compliance
and you are subject to sanctions so it's
a it's a it's a hot topic the u.s. move
has angered Germany a longtime ally
Berlin rejects the idea that Washington
can legally impose sanctions on third
parties we have long been against
extraterritorial sanctions we have the
same problem with Iran in my opinion the
only solution is to hold talks very
decisive talks where against letting
these extraterritorial sanctions take
effect
despite the anger in Berlin Germany is
not planning any action against
Washington that's not the case with
Russia the other part there in the
pipeline President Vladimir Putin has
threatened retaliation and Moscow has
made it clear it will go ahead and
finish the project whatever the United
States does